في ايران نجحت الانتفاضه الشعبيه على مدى
اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر في الحفاظ على وتيرتها
وان تراجع زخمها رغم اساليب القمع
المتنوعه التي تمارسها السلطات عبر اصدار
احكام اعدام المكثفه واعتقالات واسعه
شملات اكثر من 14 الف محتج وحرمان
المعتقلين من العلاج وارتفاع نسبه قتل
الاحتجاجات الى نحو 470 شخصا
مقابل القمع نجح المحتجون والمحتجات في
الالتفاف على الحملات الامنيه وابتكروا
اساليب وطرقا جديده بينها تغيير
استراتيجيه التظاهر من النهار الى الليل
الدعوات للتجمع عبر منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي بعض الاحتجاجات استوحت من
اغلاقات كورونا ولجات الى الشرفات للتعبير
عن معارضتها
ومع استمرار التضاهرات توسعت المطالب من
مجرد الاعتراض على فرض الحجاب الى
المطالبه باسقاط النظام الحاكم منذ الثوره
عام 1979
[موسيقى]
التغيير كان اجتماعيا ايضا انضم للطلاب
فنانون ومخرجون وممثلون اضافه الى رياضيين
ايرانيين بارزين وبدا الاحتجاج عموديا
وافقيا لدى كل شرائح المجتمع الايراني في
مؤشر يدخل دعايه السلطات واتهامها للخارج
بتحريك الداخل